[Musique]
le président cyrille melchior et les
élus du département se sont réunis ce
mercredi 2 mai au palais de la source
afin de débloquer des aides en faveur
des agriculteurs touchés par la tempête
fakir
l'assemblée a voté à l'unanimité c'est
donc une enveloppe de deux millions
trois cent soixante quatorze mille euros
qui sera débloquée en complément des
aides déjà accordé lors des précédentes
tempêtes berly taper dumazy ce matin
donc nous avons voté en commission
permanente des aides notamment pour
revenir
v à ceux et celles qui ont perdu donc
leur le récolte à l'ensemencement on va
élargir ces aides vers des productions
comme les bananes comme les papayes et
donc des produits d des arbres qui ont
été abîmés donc on élargit le dispositif
dead ensuite qu'on leur a fait c'est
qu'on va alléger des dossiers parce que
souvent les harkis de nous disent mais
le manager tas de papiers pour pouvoir
bénéficier des as du département eh bien
on va alléger tout cela ces dossiers de
façon à ce que ça aille plus rapidement
de plus le département met en place un
rsa activité afin d'aider les
agriculteurs plan de telles périodes de
crise il ya des agriculteurs qui se
retrouvent sans revenu
pas de récolte galles pas de revenus on
ne peut pas laisser des familles
entières comme cela démunis sans rien et
bien même si on lui accorde des aides
bois replanter des aides replanter leurs
champs mais il faut aussi pouvoir
survivre
humainement c'est pour cela que le
dispositif rsa activité sera mise en
place au bénéfice des familles qui en
ont besoin des familles qui n'ont plus
de revenus
à titre exceptionnel sur une période de
quatre mois pour bénéficier de cette
aide les dossiers seront à disposition
dès ce soir sur le www.defirh.fr 4 point
fr l'aide sera accordée un mois après le
dépôt des dossiers
[Musique]